You know the moon, right — the big space
rock humans landed on for the first time 50
years ago?
Well, astronauts left a lot of stuff behind
there.
Stuff like used scientific equipment, clothing,
food wrappers and, well…
their poop.
Across all 6 moon landings, Apollo astronauts
left 96 bags of human waste on the moon.
We’re talking poop.
Pee.
Vomit.
It was left behind to save weight for the
return trip.
Stuffed in big trash baggies, like this one,
dropped from Apollo 11
Inside those bags is a big, unanswered question
— a scientific mystery that I want answered:
Is there anything alive in that moon poop?
I know, I know, it sounds ridiculous.
But the answer might help us
understand how life started on Earth.
And our potential to contaminate other worlds
— like Mars — with our literal shit.
And the answer, it's not too far away.
It’s lying in wait, nearly 240,000 miles away,
on the moon.
Right here. Those — this really isn't to scale.
What I’m saying is we gotta go back for
that shit.
Human feces can be disgusting, sure. This is not — this is Play Doh.
But it’s also teeming with life.
Around half of its mass is made up of bacteria,
representing some of the 1,000-plus species
of microbes that live in our guts.
With the moon landings, we took microbial
life on Earth to the most extreme environment
it has ever been in.
And we don’t know if it can survive there.
In all the ways Earth is so hospitable to
life, the moon is not.
It does not have a protective magnetic field
to deflect the most powerful and damaging
cosmic radiation.
It doesn't have an ozone layer to absorb
the sun’s ultraviolet rays.
It doesn't have an atmosphere.
And the moon is subjected to wild temperature
swings over day and night:
A lot would have to go right for the microbes
to still be alive — or at least revivable
from a dormant state.
But there are some scientists who want to go back and check,
because there are two really fascinating things that
we can learn from this poop.
The first has to do with a planet millions
of miles away from the moon: Mars.
For decades, scientists have wondered if there’s
life on Mars — and they’re getting closer
to figuring it out.
Mars has a thin atmosphere, evidence of flowing
water, and a more hospitable environment than
the moon.
If microbes can survive on the moon, they’re
even more likely to survive on Mars.
So what if humans go to Mars and leave their
poop there and the microbes in it start
to spread?
It will be hard to tell what life we find
there is Martian and what life we brought
with us if we accidentally contaminate the
planet with our poop.
But there’s also a bigger question.
There’s a hypothesis about how life started
on Earth: that it didn’t start on Earth
at all.
That some asteroid or comet, carrying some
microbes, crashed-landed here and seeded life on the planet.
Finding living things in the moon poop could
support that hypothesis, because if microbial
life can survive on the moon, it could survive
on an asteroid, too.
And if the hypothesis is true, it could mean
life travels across the universe, jumping
from planet-to-planet, from asteroid collisions.
Here’s a wilder thought: Let’s say an
asteroid comes hurtling by, slams into the
moon, and projects the Apollo mission moon poop
into the deep reaches of space.
Could that seed life in the broader universe?
Maybe.
So how do we figure out the answer to these
great mysteries?
Easy.
We go back.
That's gonna take a lot of work and research and diving into internet clickholes.
Bad security for anything you're doing, including a project to go back to the moon, can ruin everything.
Enter: Dashlane. Dashlane is the one tool you need to stay safe online.
It helps keep you safe online and protects your most sensitive information,
and will even let you know that you've been the victim of a hack.
Dashlane can autogenerate and autofill super strong passwords on all websites where you have accounts.
It works on any browser and any device and it syncs your data instantly before all of them.
And it even includes a multi-country VPN, so you can stay safe and browse privately on any device.
So go to dashlane.com/vox to get a 30-day free trial of Dashlane Premium
and use the promo code "VOX" to get 10% off Dashlane Premium.
Dashlane doesn't directly impact our editorial, but their support makes videos like this possible.
So click the link in the description to check them out.